Russia's defense minister has claimed
that Ukraine might use a dirty bomb and
then blame Russia for it but what is a
dirty bomb
[Music]
assist information
combination of two things firstly
conventional explosives and secondly
radioactive material now that can come
from all sorts of places even hospital
equipment now it's worth saying that a
dirty bomb is not a nuclear bomb that is
much more devastating and works in a
different way but of course anything
that can explode and spread radioactive
material has the capacity to be
extraordinarily damaging
[Music]
no and that's why they are considered as
theoretical weapons now the nearest
we've had to dirty bombs being used was
in the 1990s where Chechen Rebels
prepared a couple of them one was placed
in a park in Moscow it used cesium taken
from equipment that was being used to
treat cancer patients but it was made
safe more recently there have been
reports that Al-Qaeda and Islamic State
have been investigating making dirty
bombs but there's no evidence at all
that they succeeded
foreign
[Music]
on lots of things the amount of
explosives the radioactive source and
also where and when it was exploded if
it was a really windy day for instance
that wind might well take away lots of
the radioactive dust before it could
contaminate anything but in a worst case
scenario a dirty bomb could contaminate
a wide area cause very serious health
issues and require a massive
decontamination effort before that area
was inhabitable again
foreign
[Music]
Ukraine has completely dismissed the
idea that it would use a dirty bomb it
says it doesn't have that sort of device
it doesn't have the materials you need
to make it and that it wouldn't use it
anyway Ukrainian leaders here tell us
that if any country is going to use a
dirty bomb in Ukraine
Russia and that is a thought that's been
echoed by allies in Britain America
France and at NATO they've warned Russia
that if it were to use a dirty bomb
there would be serious consequences